[Musik]
die
ich würde sagen wir machen weiter kann
man selbst richtig gut vertragen wird
jetzt 4 2 das ist ein bisschen verspätet
dazu gehört als entschädigung ein paar
keksen
[Applaus]
es geht schon los haben wir umgestellt
auf highlights zählen da haben wir ja ok
alles glas so jetzt möchte ich ihn in
diesen zwei punkt york möchte ich ihnen
die aviva methode vorstellen und ich
teile ihn dazu jetzt auch schon
die autofreien wetter sind es dass das
jetzt die grundstruktur eines tutorials
das ist eine struktur die es erlaubt
auch vermeintlich langweilige thema mit
allem haben es gibt gar keine loyalität
interessant zu anschaulichen und wie
schon sein abi ball ist ein akronym für
verschiedene methoden die darin wohnen
werden kombiniert werden
und sie hält er uns eine seminar sitzung
zu strukturieren das ist also die
aufgabe diese methode und diese methode
hat sich erklärt auch in der forschung
bisher finden sie dazu einiges dazu dass
aviva china sagen man auch nicht nur
methode amerika china lässt sich
folgendermaßen beschreiben und ganz
offen lösen habe dort ausrichten
ich gehe mal kurz durch frau bedeutet
vorwissen aktivieren die bedeutet
informieren warum bedeutet das zweite
frau bedeutet verarbeiten und das
abschließende kann
müsste dann studieren was es
abschließbar sein könnte sagen es werden
genau das also die evaluation das ist
ein ganz wichtig kann man grundsätzlich
sagen ein bisschen voraus
häufig würde es ihm so geht es mir auch
dass fliegen vorbei sind dass sie nicht
mit anderen stoff durch gekommen sind
und dann gibt es mehrere möglichkeiten
und schlechteste möglichkeit ist dann in
meinen augen einfach so lange zu machen
und den stoff um teufel komm raus
durchzupauken um fertig zu werden
das halte ich nicht betont sondern da
muss man eben wenn man abschied kommt
nicht durch kann verschiedene gründe
haben zum beispiel die diskussion so gut
liefen diskussion sollte man es gut
laufen nicht abbrechen da sie dann zu
viel riskiert haben verstrichen
in der eine gute werden konnten dann
werde er sie sexuell stellt einfach
nochmal zu kassieren und alle noch
verbliebenen themen zur sturen sind dann
empfiehlt es sich wenn wir jetzt noch
fünf minuten hatte fotos machen
beschluss wir müssen jetzt hier und
jetzt haben wir auf öffnungen zeit um
uns gedanken darüber zu machen was wir
heute gelernt hat es wurde diskutiert
haben was die ergebnisse der
intensivsten und das betrifft den
letzten punkt aus wenden was ganz
entscheidend ist dann das ganze hier ein
und dann sehen sie dass nämlich auch
genau also das ist dann auch noch ein
wichtiger punkt dass sie eben dass china
so ansetzen dass sie immer noch für sich
einplanen um nochmal revue passieren zu
lassen was jetzt gemacht und es werden
mehr
wir machen das
heute sitzung es sinnvoll sich im
zeitplan zu widersetzen
sie sagen minute so gerade macht der
hilft damit ich dann auch das sprechen
kommen es werden in der regel nicht
schafft also es so jetzt kommt immer was
dazwischen sei es dass der biber nicht
funktioniert und sie erst noch die
technik holen müssen weil es das was die
einkommen sind es kann immer
irgendwelche probleme gegeben und
deswegen machen sie sich in drogen zeit
waren sie immer füllen und auch für den
schluss dass sie hier noch einmal das
richtige projekt seminars zusammenfasst
und das bedeutet einfach
usa das derby war es letzte nacht bevor
wir mit diesen den aussichten den ersten
ab beginnen sollte man die gruppen
zusammenführen
das heißt so was wir jetzt auch gemacht
habe und aufstellung zu müssen sie es
nicht machen aber dass er sich mal
kennenlernen also dass bisher ein
gruppengefühl einen gruppen atmosphäre
entsteht
diesen ersten anflug die sollten erstmal
sich aufstellen das musste ich im raum
seien aber zum beispiel sich kennen wir
das sagen der erste zieht das hässliche
von interesse
das vielleicht bei deren teilnehmer
sagen lassen dass ihre interessen sind
und dass dessen ans leben und da schon
ein bisschen ein geologe von der
atmosphäre im kurs er ist abhängig wie
gut gelernt wird
deswegen ist diese gruppen gesamtführung
sehr sinnvoll wenn man sich kennenlernt
auftauen
ja wo stehe ich
was sind meine interessen was sind meine
erwartungen von ihrer seite als zu tun
aber auch fragen der teilnehmer jeder
interessen
erwartung und ansprüche und die kann man
gleich am anfang kommunizieren
das ist also diese manor vorgeworden
und dann geht es weiter zum ausrichten
das ausrichten ist auch ein wichtiger
kunde ganz zu beginn darum weil dass sie
da auch das thema einstimmen
also das kann sein dass jetzt zum
beispiel vorwissen auch schon bis zum
abrufen seitenwechsel punkt dass ihr
einfach mal die generelle relevanz
dieses thema jahren teilnehmen
worum geht es eigentlich darum ist das
thema wichtig also da wir kennen es
sozusagen das interesse da wirklich die
leute dann geben sie den leuten
orientierung auf das ganze skala
bedeutet dass sie den geheimen aktionen
seminarplan musste und die wichtigsten
stationen schon in teilen
also interesse motivation dort hier
grundgelegt in diesem jahr da müssen sie
die motivation basis ist da alle
weiteren schritte also der einstieg ist
das wichtigste
er könnte auch sagen senat und den höher
wodurch sich das interesse an
teilnehmern auch die aufmerksamkeit
hindurch fädeln müssen eine möglichkeit
ist nicht so ein bier treffen
forderungen zu beginn an zu die leute
abzuholen
also man könnte strauss nicht absagen
abholen hätte man sind das thema gewinne
abholen
dass ich finde dass ist die komplette
struktur aktiviert aber was damit der
körper werden oder das werden wir jetzt
auch noch kommunikation und motivation
aktivierung ist immer wer
das heißt wir sollten immer auch
körperlichen momenten mit albert es kann
auch sein dass man so besteht und sich
über das türkische jetzt gerne nach
vielleicht dürfen sich gerne machen
wir dürfen jetzt werden intention gerne
sich eine oberlage kamen extra geblieben
die solche zu kaufen also das aktivieren
bedeutet nicht nur inhaltlich zeigen das
ist nicht das wichtig dass es nicht so
dass sie abzuholen durch zu reformen
oder ob durch zb zum programm
so können sie gerade hin projizieren das
jeden witz erzählt eine anekdote oder in
zeitungsartikeln die aktuelle aktualität
da gelingt erzählt dass sie eben auch
körperlich eine physische teilnehmer
aktivieren
also immer auf diese doppelt
doppelseitig kite achten aktivierung
oder aufarbeitung ist immer sowohl mit
oder proposition erhalte richter als
auch körperlich das ist eine einheit und
die wird häufig übersehen häufig richtet
man sich nur auf das getan dass
proposition bis hin zu geben genau dann
vorwissen aktivieren prowissen zu fragen
das kann man habe alles hirnorganisch
dann zeigen
also einfach mal beleben was weiß ich
schon
und vielleicht das hängt auch mit diesen
abholen zusammen dass wir alles so oft
ähnlichen stand sind das insgesamt klar
werden wo wir stehen
der sektor stadt und den bus richtung
also ich sage im detail muss
das ist und wir müssen die teile dass
ich selbst verborgen in meinem fahrplan
das haben wir auch gemacht als sie sich
aufgestellt haben
nach sich ein vorwissen aktiviert also
ganze ein bisschen sie haben gefragt wie
ich erfahrung anzuschieben
da konnten sie sich dann in israel
bisher setzten die aktien anfangs habe
ich sie als einmal integriert
ich habe sie auf stehen lassen und
dadurch sind sie auch noch mal eine ganz
andere weise aktiv und kann nur noch
jemanden bitten das vorwissen zu
dokumentieren also ganz aufs
selbermachen ich bin ein großer freund
der documenta zu haben dass ich ihnen
immer versuchen zu sammeln die leute
vorher gesehen als es jetzt gefragt
hatte was man die besten erfahrungen mit
ihren lehrern und lehrerinnen an die
tafel geschrieben oder nachfolger wird
doch mit so finde ich ganz wichtig das
ist ein service ministerin bieten können
wenn sie in zeit haben das ist
vorausgesetzt dass sie daneben alle
ergebnisse sind es um auf oder
fotografieren den zynischen gestiftet
dann gehen sie zum schritt muss nach
tippen aber wird sie in der ortenau
wichtige punkte ordentlich schreiben
dann wurde es am ende einfach die
sanierung jetzt wendemöglichkeiten
politik eben auch dieses vorwissen zu
dokumentieren informiert dass jetzt die
vision der tod bei denen die meisten
schon beginnen also diese avantgarde
mode wird reduziert auf dieses was es da
und frau fällt weg ansonsten beginnt
gleich in medias res gleich mit der
innovation sondern wissens abladen und
das ist natürlich lieber forderung
jemand
wenn du jetzt ein bisschen das
wissensportal dahinter steckt natürlich
dann auch wieder ein
kommunikationsmodell also
[Musik]
und in diesen fragen geht das wissen
ein ganz beliebtes aber auch nicht
laufen kürzte bild ist center entringer
dass sie hier ein paar geschichten das
für medieninformation studien über so
über diese psd bank rhein und die
studenten werden zwischen sparen und das
ist natürlich sehr reduziert und das ist
ein problematisches verhältnis
verständnis und wissen vermitteln und
zwar deswegen weil sie immer auch das
thema herrn bedeute werde dann auch
bitte
für mich ist es auch leider müssen wir
das die ganze wohnung habe
experten machen
vorgestellt ich muss die konstruktion
zwischen den studenten mir
gegen genau so allgemein zu kommen genau
das ist es doch so dass dieses wissen
und information findet zum gegenstand in
bern statt
ich war keine scharfe ist dass ich
dieselbe
oder man also des problems oder das
alter hase
die idee dass bei dem informieren auch
wenn man nur damit beginnt dass man die
informationen des wissens einfach
ablehnt es geht in manchen fächern
besser manche schlechter in philosophie
in dem fach mustern wenigsten klare
wissens eingibt und alles hinterfragen
ist nicht so sehr die gegenstandes
entscheidenden turnier tode jedenfalls
hängen die art und weise in der
diskussion mit dem leben stunde
diskutieren außerdem ist jeder
gegenstand ist eine problematische der
stadt und der philosophie in anderen
fächern mögen nicht so problematisch
sein
der mann müsse hinterfragt und gemeinsam
arbeiten und deswegen ist es eine gute
idee von ihnen dass sie sagen
[Musik]
erhält ein bisschen anders diese löcher
stagniert das hingegen statt
damit bauen
[Musik]
vielleicht reden ist
hattest du gemeinsam in diesem fall ja
okay dass die sata und dem wolf soll als
der tutor hand der turner reiche dazu an
dass die studierenden sich mit dem
gegenstand einstimmig geschichte
er tritt zurück also ich glaube
tatsächlich dass das somit jahren sein
könnte dass der tour nie wirklich so
nicht geht aber er in den augen der
studierenden verschwinden und zwar so
dass er immer dann eingreifen wenn es
nötig ist aber nicht mehr richtig als
mittelstands bemerken die ihr
irgendwelche kontrolle heraus sagen dass
man menschen die auf
das ist sicherlich sehr gute idee und
sollte mich damit elektronisch das
finale dann wenn der gute am wenigsten
sich der am aktivsten sind ist die
paradoxe also dann wenn der tod von
nicht mehr gesehen wird wenn er
scheinbar unscheinbar auf ihn verzichten
kann dann ist ein mächtiges land
ich glaube das ist in den paradoxien und
das verlangt von den tutoren von der
trauerminute aber viel
einfühlungsvermögen und auch mit denke
dass libyschen bestimmte dinge
antizipiert und daneben die weichen
struktur richtig stellen damit die
studierenden in den eben ein auto wie
hält man das selbst zu erkennen es
kommen und nicht den eindruck gewinnen
müssen
der trug tor den motoren hat alles
einfach nicht nur abgemacht sind ich bin
selbst werkzeug bekommen und dass es
auch im philosophischen sinn so ein
bisschen diese idealvorstellung mio und
so konnte es also die hebammen kurzen
gegen studenten müssen das wissen selbst
hervorbringen und wir austoben können
ihnen hilfestellung das ist jetzt sehr
idealistisch gedacht aber einfach als
art hintergrund sollte nicht unbedingt
immer dass ich den job für spiele müssen
dass sie hier alles tun müssen
nutzen sie
die internierten das potenzial ihrer
teilen da ist nämlich sehr viel
enthalten
versuchen sie lieber diese potenziale zu
decken als ihnen alles zu das
erleichtert auch ihre stellungen nicht
mehr und großem druck steht dass die
masse studieren zu verlassen dass sie
selbst den ergebnissen kommen und sie
lieben da eingreifen notwendig ist dann
schaltet zu verschieden aber sind
eigentlich immer total und das ist so
dieser business in und ein guter punkt
und da beginnt leider immer hier ist die
ganze geschichte ohne dieses ausrichten
und es vor ist praktisch das ist eben
braucht damit man soll das import
kommunikatives verhältnis nicht hier
vorne steht jemand da sitzt jemand sind
nur drinnen immer im dialog und das kann
auch bedeuten dass wir aufstehen
wir kommen nach einem gleichauf liegen
methoden zu sprechen verarbeiten
kritische auseinandersetzung mit dem
wissen ob ich nicht sagen studierende
durch kritischen ansätzen alles zu
fragen nichts als selbstverständlich
anzunehmen wichtig ist auch
auflockerungen
also was soll das unterschätzen raten
nach dem essen gibt dieses stichwort
nachmittags tief es gibt es auch eine
kurve oder mögen wir sagt man mir geht
es immer anders und ich habe meine
tiefste anderen zeigen können aber man
sagt gewürdigt dass nach dem mittag ist
ein motivationstief das sei weil er
irgendwie verdauen
ich weiß nicht besonders aktiv wenn das
der fall ist wenn wir das werk tutorium
am von 12 bis 14 uhr
meine seminare gegenüber als bisher zu
hören aber ich habe noch kein schlechter
fang gemacht
dann empfiehlt es sich auch nicht
bearbeiten wirklich auf ihre
körperlichen grenzen gekommen damit dass
diese methode einsetzen wurde ihr euch
auch aufstehen und sich bewegen muss
also nicht so dass albert hätten aber
dass man wie sie anfangen und nicht
immer noch ist
es gibt den spruch von jüdische glaube
ich dass mit der philosoph und in
philosophie des sitzens des stehens und
des gehens es stehen zwei sind er auch
das gms unterteilen können
und er ist erst dann philosophieren
bedeutet gegeben nicht nur zu 1600
gegeben zum beispiel auch durch die
banane zerrung der mann
gerade uns sehr gut man kann sich durch
in diesem beispiel lernerfolgen also man
sieht es ja nicht automatisch dass es
solche auch aktivität und bewegung ist
abläufe integriert wenn sie innerhalb
motiviert also ich heute irgendwo im
raum
serbien das motivieren zum beispiel wir
wollen es machen können in den größen
haben können sie auch das wissen
räumlich organisieren das heißt sie
können ein
punkt meiner seite gefestigt haben dann
ist es gut ein antrag zum beispiel kann
eine gruppe 1 1 bestimmt und auch ein
stückchen ort im raum gesetze und die
andere kommen und dann können sie das
ist auch schon lokalisieren das heißt es
wird einem stabilem anspruch und die
leute werden durch ihre bewegung mit dem
wissen ganz an das verhältnis gesetzt
als dieses leben hier bloß verstehen und
das wissen profess ablegte
seit der ruhig ein bisschen kreativ dazu
sind tutorien da bei
seminarveranstaltung mache ich so was
die erzählen weil ich häufig sehr viele
teilnehmer und ist in ihren reihen
festgestellt da kann einem
studienwechsel
[Musik]
anfangs nicht diejenigen zum beispiel
für das was dann für alle kennen also
machen wir doch mal
doch es gehört wie sein werde
ich suche mir sozusagen das max kruse
ist aus der aktuellen medialen szenerie
aus dem kino brillen oder
heute machen und reden
ja also das ist alles möglich und das
kommt vor einem wendepunkt ausrichten
oder aktivieren hinein
da können sie mit zu wasser wirklich an
die leute als ambitioniert
ich habe ihm dann eine zeitungsnotiz
heute entspannt auf der bild zeitung
ganz groß sagte einst das war so und
dann die relevanz entstehen oder so
können abend eingefangen was hat das mit
unserem guten tutorials thema zu tun
dann haben sie nämlich zweite sie haben
ihre aktualität ist haben die wissen
ihre chance die leute müssen achten und
sie haben einen bekommen die chronische
krankheiten einsetzen kann
das führte der erste punkt ist dass
gerade besonders wichtig aber natürlich
können sie auch immer wieder wir haben
das früher von jungen sie können immer
wieder auch kleine ironische
wenn sie sachen und das kann sich durch
jeden einzelnen durchziehen
auch beim verarbeiten können sie
wiederum aktivieren aus womit sie sich
dann ich jetzt hat es gestaltet sind
sie können das flexibilisieren das sind
nur so generellen realistische
perspektive
generell so dass amazon zum beispiel
angebot wobei ich zusammenfassen letzten
geeignet halter für das dann auswerten
für den letzten punkt da sie dann also
verarbeiten einfach kritische
auseinandersetzung durchaus ein spieler
weg und hier kommt dann die methoden den
schuldigen im im nächsten genommen
es gibt es ganz verschiedene methoden
zum beispiel zuruf liste oder
trüffelschwein
ganz kuriosen haben und diese methoden
können sie dann auch noch daheim
anwenden denn sie arbeiten geht und
jeder punkt hier kamen gesetzt werden
mit verschiedenen konkreten methoden
nicht nur zu sprechen kann aus werden
[Musik]
heißt auch immer feedback geben und
feedback nehmen also zum beispiel auch
unterstellen sie dann den letzten fünf
minuten jungen und das würde die
möglichkeiten nutzen für den patienten
also aus werden
das hatte ich wurde also nicht
durchsetzen jedenfalls hier
das ganze jetzt noch durchbringen müssen
in welchem feld einfach noch gedacht
haben müssen das jetzt größen ein
stoppschild nicht durchgekommen und
diesen gut machen zu einer aber wir
kommen im nächsten sitzen mehrere
minister
fünfmal zu diskutieren und zu erklären
was wir gemacht haben
so gab es noch offene fragen was ist
unklar was aber mitgenommen was könnte
man noch machen
also lassen sie sich in ihrer modelle
anstellung übernommen zeitfenstern
übrigen um außerdem mit abwechslung
anzustellen was hat uns das jetzt
gebracht was ist jetzt
das kann natürlich auch immer das gros
werden können immer mehr wenn der
anderen schritte auch beim informieren
können sie schon einfließen lassen warum
das wichtig ist und sind menschen mit
einer müssen dass nicht er ist ganz
allein gemacht aber es ist erst so dass
sie bestimmte schwer damit das setzen
also alle punkte spielen sie jeder
moment aber gewisse punkte haben größere
bedeutung im globalen zu
also tendenziell sollte man hier aus
werden einfach mal vorlesen aktivieren
oder als informieren ende mich besser
für information eines affen
konstellationen wasser großen am ende
einfach aus werden reflektieren fragen
offene fragen entgegen nehmen vielleicht
auch im ausblick noch mal machen was
kommt danach
er ist lange also ganz wichtig
außerdem reisen gegen mittag ist eine
metapher ausgenommen wenn da schwingt
noch was mit plan heißt licht abbruch
oder aufbruch oder so dass es am ende
nicht abschneiden oder klingen noch was
nach dann schwingt noch das mit der rote
faden der sich einfach abgeschnitten
sind der leute zu lange seien aussagen
über gülle und mist sind also nicht
abrupt micha prozent was wirklich in m
days dann sinnvoll wenn sie an dem die
zugleich auf das neue hinweise
also ein ende ist auch immer wieder mit
einem abschneiden sind so leicht sein
so dass hunt jetzige markt groß geworden
und jetzt kommt der nächste schritt
haben und das leben ist ein ausblick auf
das was danach folgt das erlaubt das wm
teilnehmern dass das wenige was sie
gelernt haben
im größeren kontext zu zitieren ist ganz
wichtig immer zu wissen wo stehe ich
jetzt im kontext des gesamten teams
also sollte anfang ist besonders wichtig
und ein ende und das ende wird meistens
fachlichen kenntnisse mit diesen themen
wie möglich und auch durch eine junge
star und diesen text selber noch lesen
und jetzt kommen die ersten leute reihen
und der nächsten veranstaltung schon ein
derart unter druck und sei das leiden
wir haben können sie auch die werber das
hier könnte es wieder getan derzeit 150
verändere ich möchte uns mit dem
abschließenden
rückblick zu machen
[Musik]
zurückzuführen dass im wichtigsten und
das bleibt besonders in der inneren
abteilung anmerkung zu diesem ausflug
oder wen würden sie gerne einen rückgang
solltet ihr es ein bisschen besser auf
das ende gemacht und das ende konnte
leider immer zu kurz und das ende ist
und gleichzeitig der anfang ist
natürlich auch sehr wichtig aber das
ende wirklich immer fünf minuten
einplanen vielleicht stellte sich auch
einfach
zum vibrationsalarm dass ich sage wenn
von dem zeugen geändert nicht gewährt
machen und das ist ein signal für mich
jetzt abzubrechen
dass man lege auch zu sagen wenn dann
füllt nun nur noch für eine große lange
zu verwenden dritten gewannen sie das
ist so dieses schema rückblick und vor
blicken also was hat er gemacht und was
bekommen aber auch ganz wichtig und
jetzt möchte ich hier diesem kontext
auch dieses sozialfonds eingehen also
wie verhalte ich mich gegenüber den
studierenden
es betrifft nämlich vor allem diesen
punkt
informieren die leider immer noch sehr
häufige form zu unterrichten bestehen in
diesem
frontalunterricht und sein wissen abgeht
das ist dann ein bisschen monologischen
ich sag jemals ist und sie empfangen das
zunehmend auf und sie mit
[Musik]
dagegen spricht grundsätzlich nichts sie
können gerne solche monologischen
situation ein
was nicht gerade machen das macht es
auch in und ich frage mal zwölf bands im
freigaben kannst du sagen aber wir sind
momentan so ein teil des senders das ist
einfach in das blut so ist das ist an
sich nicht schlecht
es sollte halt nicht die einzige methode
sein und sie sollte auch nicht zu
wackeln als sonst nach italien müssen
sie immer wieder aktivieren
das ist plenum frontal oder gibt es aber
im plenum interaktiv des c4 deshalb
nicht gerade zu machen zu machen
versuchen dass es pläne also sie sitzt
in ihrem plädoyer nicht steht davor und
ich versuche ihnen hier einerseits
frontal aus zu vermitteln
total beim ich versuche aber immer auf
wiedersehen einzubeziehen
durch bestimmte fragen ohne möglichkeit
dass ihr untergang stehen also das ist
aber auch partner und pankow
das erst auf wenn ihr sie methoden
einsetzen die listen mit der methode
kastens den nächsten schritt zeigen
angebracht die möglichkeit dass es sagen
wir wählen jetzt einfach mal ab ob 3d
debatte und drei machen lassen also
siedlung ein bestimmendes thema oder sie
diskutieren irgendwann droht da gibt es
dann die mitmenschen und methoden
kastens das sollte dass ich noch immer
überlegen in seminare kommen dass man
die musik kommt also das sei eben gleich
als vorwarnung und damit ein teil wenn
sie dann wir den studierenden so und
jetzt nach methoden
dann werden sie manchmal das was die
bahn fließen jährlich im
kindergartenalter so alles an methoden
einsatz muss auch wieder vorbereitet
werden das heißt ob die studierenden
müssen ausgerichtet werden vorbereitet
auf die methode und da wo ich nur sagen
fassen sie auch diese möglichkeit nimmt
haben oder noch
das ist alles geht mindestens drei ist
einfach total und der interaktive und
nicole ihre teilnehmer dann selbst
aktivieren eines arbeiters möglichkeit
das sagen
jeder geht jeder hat den text vor sich
dem leben riskieren darf nicht zu lange
das ist eine halbzeit
und jetzt macht sich jeder weise am 5
zeit und jeder noch zu vage und dann
sammeln ich bin nicht so ein großer
freund der einst arbeit weil ich glaube
dass graf philosophierte jeder
gegenstand der milizionäre hätten meinte
logisch und ubs
diskutiert werden soll das heißt er
würde in diesem fall also einem partner
arbeiten schlagen
text und jeder der beiden listen und
dann diskutieren und dann zahlen medien
akzeptieren
so war es denn auch eine methode
ja das war es von dieser seite zum thema
ein sozialraum und aviva stahnsdorf
überhaupt diesen schlimmen sie diese
lieber schön das sollten sie sich gut
eintreten so dahin
die seele des gespiegelt aus ein
bisschen alles vertreten sicherung
dieses dieses informieren hatte dieses
reine wissensvermittlung ist eingebettet
in einen kontext dieser also stellte das
so verbessern savage dass in familien
die information dass pudel dass das ist
das ist nicht der anfang des endes kommt
mit daraufhin wird hin gearbeitet und
darüber in der reflektierte des
bauteiles führe dort eine wegführung in
der zib sagt diesen harten klimatischen
kern gerade der philosophie immer
problematisch ist in der hechinger
diskutiert deswegen beziehungstipps
urlauber mit ein
wie sie zur nachbarin aus westlichen
gibt waren und zunächst auch genutzt
werde diese einreichen darf das ausland
insbesondere auf die evaluation am ende
wo sie wirklich ist und kennen das ist
ganz wichtig weil das kleid der auf
ihren studierenden im gedächtnis und so
könnten auch hier die nächste sitzung
beginnen wenn sie zb geträumte machen
oder noch mal zweiter
reflektiven kommen können sie die
nächste sitzung damit wieder bedienen
lassen dass ein prinzip ganz am ende den
letzten fünf minuten hatten wir dass es
das auch gemacht dass man nicht nur die
paulsons wichtigsten gehört neben
sonntag einstellungen eingenommen und zu
diesem thema und da setzt knüpfen wir
jetzt wieder haben sie wieder die
aktivierung der nächsten sitzung also
denkt ist in den letzten versuchen ihre
tutorium sind zu machen die nächsten
morgen in der nächsten sitzung dass sie
da ist er sich einen kritischen
gesichtsausdruck familie ist ihr das
denn
viele kurse immer sehr intensiv wie wir
so nebenbei noch arbeiten einfach
das foyer spanischen texte vorbereitet
werden nicht noch alles
etwa weil sie meine fragen die demos vor
der bühne sind
was ist da schon werden den hinweis dass
man zu machen dass das kann er das nicht
meine ich selber erlebt habe
was damit das beste wenn man ende dass
das mit
sondern ein schockmoment zugeben dass
dieses rahmens nachdem das geklärt
werden
diese wichtigen gedanken länger
nachhallt genommen vom einschalten
[Musik]
es war nicht so einfach
tja das ist die studenten dann wenn sie
auf dem weg in den nächsten stunden mir
das
oder kommt oder kommt sucht man kann
natürlich sagen es ist gespiegelt das
sehen sie wachse die angst dass die
innovative informieren dass gespielt
wird und passiert sagt das verwenden die
meisten nicht häufig am anfang auf der
hoffnung machen
dieser tremor wenn dieses schockieren
oder dieses irgendwie in andere jägerin
das setzt man drei weiteren anfangen
aber ich finde es auch gut dass klang
nicht nur so als es das richtige essen
zu nehmen sind die leute da habe ich auf
zu denken muss hat bedenken dass die
häufig am ende gedanklich schon längst
seminar sind natürlich offen sind
wir haben das heißt die beste freund
würde ich mir für antwort also mit mit
der besten orte mit dem was auch immer
interessanten zeitungsartikel oder sie
können auch gerne ein video einspruch
und so gut gehen lassen würde
zum anfang die dass die konzentration
die erwartungshaltung sehr vermisst wird
antreten das problem dass man die leute
nicht mehr so richtig weil der standard
möchte ich deswegen am ende würde ich
sagen nicht mehr zu viel im code auf
anregende methode sind ja
zusammenfassende auswertung reflektieren
und dann ausbringen aus ist es aber was
sie zb gutmachen könnte jetzt sollen
nachdenke fragen der auf dem weg möchten
wir dass sie nachher nicht den eindruck
erhalten teilnehmer ihr weiß der punkte
sein sondern besteht dass wenn ich immer
dass ich sagen wir beginnen mit brandon
das tutorium ich mit dem punkt der seite
zu gehen will soll man mir diese frage
sind wir haben hier natürlich mit ihnen
auf dem heimweg geben
dann haben sie das dann eine fülle von
1000 gehalten und dann geht mein
mittagessen und kann darüber fällt
wurde das war und ist uns ein halbes
jahr hatte das leben nicht an sich den
anspruch haben müssen kritisieren den
prozess sind lassen sich ausklingen
ich denke wegen der konzentration wäre
es besser die partie am ende am anfang
zu machen
aber sie könnten aus und du kannst jetzt
nicht hundertprozentig sagen vielleicht
klappt das
dass sie dabei besonders aktiv aber es
ein guter punkt dass man also immer
versucht und gewisse prozent anzusetzen
und nicht alles auf den punkt wenn er
diesen sommer sagte
die ganze kultur ist haben sie sonst
noch fragen
falls nicht würde ich sagen wenn diesen
und wohin wir auch live stream und